The plant-based diet is abundant in nutrients.
As long as you are choosing a large variety of fruits,
veggies, whole grains, beans, nuts, seeds, tofu, tempeh,
all of those incredible ingredients.
You're gonna get everything that you need.
The health benefits that I've seen in my patients
in the short term and the long term,
and what we see in the data as well,
show us that a plant-rich and even a plant-exclusive diet
is brilliantly healthy.
(upbeat music)
Greetings, internet. Welcome to the podcast.
Today, we're back, talking diet, talking nutrition,
and overall wellbeing
with an additional focus on hormone health,
particularly, but not exclusively, women's hormone health.
And we're gonna do it with Dr. Gemma Newman.
Gemma is a graduate of the University of Wales
College of Medicine.
She has expertise in a variety of specialties,
and serves as a senior partner
at a family medicine practice in the UK.
She is also the author of "The Plant Power Doctor,"
a primer on the power of plant-based nutrition
to prevent and reverse many common chronic illnesses
from diabetes and heart disease to obesity,
as well as the science that explains why it works.
Gemma first appeared on the show
almost exactly three years ago, RRP 449.
It was quite a popular episode, in case you missed it.
And today, she's back to get granular
on the relationship between nutrition and hormones
with a focus, but again, not an exclusive focus on women.
We talk endometriosis, fibroids, menopause,
testosterone replacement therapy,
important foods, nutrients, and supplements
to best balance our hormones, and many other topics.
It's worth pointing out that I learned quite a bit
from this conversation.
It's not just for the women out there.
Plenty of valuable information for everybody.
So do me a huge favor,
take a beat, and quickly hit that subscribe button
and notification bell you see right down there
in the right hand corner.
Thank you very much, and enjoy this conversation
with the wise and wonderful Dr. Gemma Newman.
We're here, we're doing it.
Yeah.
It took a minute, didn't it?
It did.
You were supposed to come something like six months ago.
Yeah, but then-
Richard got COVID.
Yeah.
So that got delayed
and then I wasn't sure if you were ever gonna make it out,
but here you are.
But I'm here.
I'm so delighted to sit with you today.
I'm delighted to be here I really am.
I haven't been to LA in nearly 20 years.
So it's been really cool.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well, you picked a nice moment.
We had some rain the other day, which was very unusual,
but everything's uncharacteristically green.
Yeah.
You must feel very,
much like, it feels like this is the Ireland time of year.
It will quickly turn brown, but right now it's pretty great.
It is.
We were driving here this morning
and I thought, "Wow, this looks so British."
Yeah.
And it's so much green.
I know.
Really surprised me.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well, we did it just for you Gemma.
Thank you.
To I make you feel at home.
I did.
And I was trying to remember the last time I saw you.
Was it at the retreat or was it when I was in London?
I can't remember.
I mean, everything's a blur because of COVID.
Yeah I think the pandemic changes
and it warps time slightly.
For sure.
Probably at the retreat.
'Cause I saw you in London
between that and the last I saw you.
I can't remember the order of events,
the older I get.
Yeah.
I don't remember what came before what.
It's okay.
But anyway,
you are here, lots of stuff to talk about.
And because the first time you were on the show
was many years ago,
and also because it was recorded at the retreat
in kind of a fireside format,
I think it would be helpful in instructive
to just sort of introduce yourself,
your background a little bit.
And this journey that you've been on
that led you to being this advocate
for the plant-based lifestyle.
Okay.
So I've been a doctor now for oh, 18 years,
and I always knew I wanted to be a doctor.
I felt that very strongly from a young age.
But in my medical training, I think it's fair to say,
I didn't necessarily look after myself,
a lot of late nights, a lot of studying.
And then when I went into actually being a doctor,
again, there was loads of night shifts, and-
Does anyone look after themselves as a medical student
or as a young doctor?
Probably not.
I mean, there's really not a lot of room for that.
(Gemma laughs)
Probably not.
That would be an unusual outlier case, I would think.
You're right I think it would be.
And although there is,
I don't know what it's like in the US,
but in the UK there this time for sports
and stuff like that, sort of recreational stuff,
but I didn't really partake of that.
I was a real bookworm.
And yeah, I partied as well, of course,
but I think it's safe to say
that my focus was not my health then.
Mm-hmm.
Like you say,
most doctors at that stage
don't really focus on health too much, which is ironic.
But I felt like when I started work,
something had to change.
'Cause I was exhausted all the time.
And I was falling asleep.
I was coming home from late shifts and I thought,
"I can't be doing this job for the rest of my life
whilst feeling this way."
So I knew something had to change.
And at that time, I hadn't done a great deal of research.
I just thought, well, I will calorie count,
I will exercise, and I will cut the carbs
because that's what the background hum was telling me to do.
In med school, I learned about nutritional deficiencies.
I learned pathology, and anatomy,
and communication skills, and lots of other things,
but not a great deal about wellness nutrition.
So fast forward, I did brilliantly with that.
I got my energy back.
I felt great.
I was proud of myself.
Then I realized, to my dismay,
that I still had risk factors for heart disease.
I checked my lipid profiles and they were still raised.
And I thought back then
that there was nothing I could do about it.
That it was just genetic.
It was my destiny.
And I'd have to cope with that later in life.
Mm-hmm.
And then fast forward a few years,
my husband Richard introduced me
to your book "Finding Ultra."
Oh yeah, that's right.
I forgot about that.
Yeah.
And he was running a marathon.
He was doing initially quite badly.
He was getting inflamed, injured.
And then he decided after reading your book
and a few others that he'd go plant-based.
And that was my first introduction to plant-based living.
I was skeptical.
I know we talked about this before,
but I watched closely with skepticism.
He did brilliantly.
His next marathon training run,
he did like an hour and 10 minutes faster.
That got me really interested.
Mm-hmm.
Not from an athletic
point of view.
I have done a couple of marathons myself,
but I wouldn't call myself
someone that's particularly athletic
or focused on performance.
For me, it was about my patience.
So were you on board eating that way also
in tandem with him?
Or you were just observing him doing that
and making mental notes?
Yeah.
Skeptical mental notes.
Yeah, I was observing. (laughs)
Uh-huh.
I didn't actually start.
So two different types
of meals happening in the household?
Yeah that's right.
He was cooking for himself for a while
and I was just watching and learning.
And don't get me wrong.
I had already read a little bit
about the environmental side of plant-based living
after he introduced me to your book and a couple of others.
So I knew that there were
some definite environmental benefits
to plant-based nutrition,
but I didn't have that kick myself.
I just didn't feel like I could do it.
It seemed too difficult.
It seemed, oh, I don't know, a bit pious and not really me.
Mm-hmm.
I had all these preconceived ideas about what it meant.
Right.
This will mean that you're gonna end up
carrying a picket sign? (chuckles)
Yeah. (chuckles)
Walking around angry.
(Gemma laughs)
With Birkenstocks on.
Well, yeah, no, I think for me,
I just thought, yeah, there were certain stereotypes
that I had contributed, sort of thought about
what it meant to be plant-based, what it meant to be vegan.
And I felt like that wasn't my identity at that time.
So he did brilliantly.
And I thought,
"Well, if he can do so well just running a marathon,
what could it do for health?
What could it do for my patients?"
I was thinking about heart disease, diabetes, cancer,
our biggest killers in the western world.
Could it make a difference?
And I realized through many years of reading
that, yes it could.
I decided to jump in.
I did it myself.
And I reaped the benefits.
My cholesterol went down.
I used to get a lot of knee aches as well
when I was running, all through my 20s, that stopped.
So that's my own personal experience.
But of course it's not...
That's not what I base my practice on.
Mm-hmm.
I have to read the research as well.
But what I found was
that it was really beneficial for my patients.
And that's when I felt, the magic really happened for me
is when I could see with my own eyes,
the changes that my patients had experienced.
And that fueled my passion.
And I've been really passionate about it ever since.
So talk to me a little bit about the transition
from you experiencing firsthand, the benefits of this,
your blood panels, improving, et cetera, and moving towards,
then advising or advocating this approach
with your patients.
'Cause those are two different things.
Yeah they are two different things.
And I thought long and hard
before I started to talk about this with my patients,
because I knew that there would be
a burden of evidence if you like.
Like if I was gonna be saying something to my patients,
I needed to know that what I was saying was evidence-based.
And so it took me a lot longer to have the courage really,
to start talking about it.
But I think what many people don't realize
is that a lot of the data exists
and it has existed for a long time.
And it actually forms the basis of a lot of guidelines.
It's just that we are perhaps not consciously aware of that.
So the World Cancer Research Fund, for example,
tells us that fruits and veggies and whole grains and beans,
are the cornerstone of a cancer preventing diet.
The American College of Cardiology
talks about plant-based diets
for prevention of heart disease.
We have the American Association of Clinical Endocrinologist
talk about how it's really helpful for preventing diabetes.
And in the UK, we've got the Royal College of GPs,
they've got their Green Impact Scheme.
So there's actually a lot of sort of,
approval if you like, from large bodies
that are involved with disease and nutrition.
But I think still there is that reluctance
in a lot of people to really sort of take it in.
Well, I think there's a couple things.
I mean, first of all, there's this notion
that many medical practitioners have that
lifestyle advice doesn't really land with the patient.
Like, "I can tell 'them to do it,
but they're not gonna do it.
So I just need to give them these meds.
And tell them to maybe not eat so much,"
or just some really general basic stuff.
Yeah.
But the reluctance
is from this place of low adoption rates.
Yeah, I think, yeah, you're right.
And you have to believe
that your patient is capable of change, I think,
in order to start talking about it.
And that's hard because nobody likes to be told what to do.
And doctors like telling people what to do. (chuckles)
Because I think we've done a lot of training.
We wanna make things right.
We wanna help people.
So we feel like if only they'd listen to us,
then you know-
Right.
They would-
I think people want their doctor
to tell them what to do though.
Do you think so?
I think people abdicate too much responsibility
to their doctor's advice in general.
And I don't know what it's like in the UK,
but in the United States,
a general practitioner, like yourself,
only has a few minutes with each patient.
And so there's not enough time
to go into great detail on all kinds of lifestyle advice.
And there's no kind of follow up or accountability
because those systems aren't in place,
it's really just diagnosed, prescribe,
move on to the next person.
And it's not the fault of the practitioner,
it's just the way the system is set up.
Yeah.
Do you feel that in your practice,
like have a little bit more bandwidth
to spend time with patients
and follow up with them, et cetera?
'Cause that piece is so important to all of this.
It is important.
And it's honestly the reason I went into medicine.
And I think that I do have a great advantage
if I think about it now,
because working in National Health Service,
I have a patient list, nearly 3,000 patients.
It's actually a really small practice.
It's equivalent to one full-time doctor.
So 3000 people under my care.
And we have only 10 minutes.
So yes, you're right.
We do have a very short amount of time.
It's not a great deal of time to talk about lifestyle.
However, we do have the ability to bring people back.
We have that sense of continuity.
Because it's free at the point of care.
People don't have to pay anything to see me.
And people can come and see me
as often as they want to.
Right.
They just need to book an appointment.
So it's very, I'd say certainly compared to the US,
it's very easy to book an appointment.
There's still a lot of complaints, generally in society,
about how easy it is to get a doctor's appointment.
But I think if we compare our healthcare system
to the one here in the US, it's much easier.
And I'm able to offer that accountability.
And also, that support and that feeling of care
that I think is really lacking perhaps
when you're dealing with a system
where it's very much drugs, prescribed, next, you know?
Right.
So yeah,
I do think I'd have a lot more freedom in that respect.
And that's what I love about it.
I love looking after my patients from cradle to grave.
Again, it's slightly different where I work
because we deal with everything.
We deal with pediatric issues-
Obstetric issues, elderly care issues,
everything and anything, people come to us first.
Whereas I think here,
they would more likely go to a specialist in their field.
It depends, yeah.
Well, yeah, if you have something acute,
you're gonna find the specialist,
but for the everyday stuff, I feel like a lot of that now
is in these urgent care centers that are all over the place.
So there isn't, at least from my experience,
and I don't know what it's like for most people,
but I don't have like a good relationship with a single GP
that I go to see that kind of knows what's up with me.
Yeah.
It's just, if something flares up,
I go to urgent care that needs immediate attention.
Yeah.
And I think we're seeing the disappearance
of that patient-doctor relationship
because of the big HMOs and all that kind of thing.
Yeah.
I see that happening a little bit in the UK,
but I think we still do have
a lot more of that relationship.
And I've got patients that have been with me.
I've been at that practice now for 14 years.
And I've seen people grow up.
I've seen families change.
Babies born.
Yeah, it's nice.
People, yeah, passing away.
And sort of that whole cycle of life.
I've seen it.
I've been there for it.
And I love it.
That's why I became a doctor, so.
So you're gonna see a little bit of everything,
but I suspect the low hanging fruit
or what you see quite frequently are lifestyle ailments
like certainly obesity, diabetes and heart disease, right?
Yeah.
Which are kind of the bullseye problems
that a plant-based, plant-centric, plant-predominant diet
has shown to be quite beneficial in ameliorating
or reducing the symptomology and the underlying causes.
Absolutely and you're right,
that's the bread and butter really of what I see.
Mostly high blood pressure and diabetes.
And certainly in terms of chronic care.
But you'll be surprised, there's a lot of other things
that can also be affected by plant-based nutrition,
which we may come onto.
But I get a lot of people
suffering from hormonal health issues-
Endometriosis, fibroids, period pains, menopausal issues.
And believe it or not,
those things as well can be improved potentially
by eating more plants.
And other issues, bowel disorders.
I get a lot of people with gastrointestinal issues as well.
So yeah, there is quite a broad range of things
that can be affected.
And it's lovely to be able to implement that.
I don't necessarily manage
to change the diet of everybody that comes in.
Sure.
Because people come with their own ideas,
their own concerns, their own expectations.
But if they're open to suggestions,
then yeah, it can be really special.
Is it a situation in which,
now that you have this book out,
"The Plant Power Doctor," right?
Like, "Oh, she's 'The Plant Power Doctor.'
Like, if I go in there, she's gonna tell me to eat this way.
Like I don't wanna deal with that.
I'm gonna go to this other doctor."
(Gemma chuckles)
I don't think I've had that yet.
You see what I try and do with my patients is,
if they're interested,
I'll refer them to my website, which is free,
and there's loads of free resources on there.
So I don't tend to sell too much.
But you're in the media, you're out there.
People know who you are, come on.
You'd be surprised, in my town,
I think people don't tend to sign up to me because of that.
But a few of my patients have caught on
to the things that I'm doing online
and they follow me online.
So I do have to be mindful of that.
Right.
But yeah.
Yeah, balancing,
the public version of yourself
and the daily practitioner version.
Yeah, it's hard.
Because you know,
I think people do have certain expectations
of what their doctor should be,
and how their doctor should be.
Right I don't want you going on podcasts all the time.
You're supposed to be like in the office,
like looking at my labs.
(Gemma laughs)
Exactly.
Right?
But no, I think I've had mostly,
if not all, positive feedback.
And people have been really inspired.
And it's been lovely actually.
It's been a really nice addition to my practice.
And one that I'll be forever grateful for.
Because that's why I wrote the book.
It was about kind of widening my circle of compassion,
making sure that people
who wouldn't have otherwise been on my list
know about this information in a really accessible way.
You know, it's full color, and pictures,
and flickable, and easy to access,
and it's got the recipes too.
So it's literally, I wanted to make it dead simple.
Well, you achieved that.
It's a beautiful book.
So congrats.
Thank you.
You mentioned hormones a couple minutes ago,
and I want to get into that.
People who have been longtime listeners
or viewers of this show, know that I've had all manner
of whole food plant-based advocates on the program,
medical professionals, including two recent appearances
by our mutual friend, Simon Hill.
And over the last nine years,
I feel like I've covered most of the issues
regarding this lifestyle on the role of nutrition
and health generally.
But one area that I admit to not having covered
with any particular focus or intensity
is women's health specifically.
How this differs from general health advice,
and the role of food and hormones.
So how do we find our way into this topic?
I mean, maybe start with some thoughts
about when you say women's health, like what does that mean?
How is that different from just human health in general?
And we can get more focus from there.
Yeah, so I mean, I did do extra qualifications
in obstetrics and gynecology, OBGYN, you'd call that here.
And family planning,
as part of, sort of my work as a doctor.
So for a while I worked in family planning as well.
And I think it's not that women's health
is over and above different
in terms of nutrition to men's health,
but that there are various considerations
that we would have physically that men don't have.
Now obviously, the most common thing would be
the fact that we have periods,
and we are kind of bound by that sort of natural cycle
from the age of puberty to the age of menopause.
Menopause itself is a huge life transition,
which doesn't occur in the same way with men.
I think because primarily
because there's less of a fluctuation
and a sort of steep decline in hormones
in a relevant to men's health.
It's more of a gradual decline-
Yeah.
As opposed
to a precipitous one.
Exactly, it's much more gradual.
And I think that helps to ameliorate symptoms.
Whereas for women,
going through perimenopause up to menopause,
then you can actually have wild fluctuations of estrogen.
It can go way up, it can go way down.
And that's really one of the main things
that's sort of responsible
for a lot of the symptoms that women will get
around their perimenopause, which we can, I suppose define.
But you know, hormones affect men too, obviously.
They affect everybody.
There's actually over 50 different hormones
and they have to work together in synergy
in order for us to perform at our best.
And it affects every aspect of our lives,
not just puberty, menopause, periods, fertility,
but everything, mood, energy, our skin,
it affects sperm counts, all sorts of things.
So it's actually integral to all humans,
but I'd say for women,
there are a lot more considerations, especially around yeah,
the fact that we carry children and that we have periods
and that we have to go through menopause,
which are very distinct life phases
that do require extra thought and attention, I think.
And so what is the role that nutrition can play in this,
and also lifestyle habits?
So if we talk first about periods, perhaps,
'cause that's probably one of the main things
that women will focus on
from around about the age of 11 or 12.
The quality of your period can change
based on the nutrition that you have.
So period are starting earlier,
which I think is an interesting thing.
I don't think that's just because of extra nutrition.
I think there are also other factors at play
with regard to environmental pollutants
and things like that.
I think there's a lot of reasons
why girls are starting their periods earlier.
And that's really significant because essentially
that means that our growth is kind of done.
We don't tend to get much taller after we start our periods.
And I think if you go through puberty
and start your periods too early,
it can put you at increased risk
of actually things like heart disease at a younger age.
Oh, I never heard that.
Yeah, which is a really interesting thing.
And I think there's just a lot of extra hormone exposures
in our environment
that we haven't been able to consider before, so-
Meaning like environmental toxins
toxins in skincare products, et cetera?
In our foods that are dysregulating
our natural hormonal cycles?
Yeah, exactly.
And things that mimic estrogens in our body.
Plastics, for example, phthalates, BPA,
they have hormone mimicking effects,
which I think do affect things like fertility
and men's sperm counts, but also, potentially also affect
when young girls and women start their periods.
So yeah, there's a lot to consider now
that we haven't really considered in the past
because they didn't exist.
But I think in terms of practical things
that people can do?
Increased fiber is so important.
Main reason being that if you are constipated,
you are actually potentially recycling
unwanted hormones through the body.
Hormones that you would otherwise got rid of,
you are actually reabsorbing.
So trying to make sure that young girls and well children,
and everybody in general doesn't get constipated
is quite a good way of reducing our excess hormone exposure.
I think it's important to mention that,
our fat cells in our body are also hormonally active.
They can produce estrogen.
So if we have more of those,
then we also have more exposures to estrogen
as a result of that, which can affect men as well as women.
But I think that that's a really important thing
that again, is not necessarily talked about much.
The fact that our fat is also hormonally active too.
Yeah.
And yeah, so I think fiber is a really important thing.
It reduces our hormone exposures.
It helps us to produce short chain fatty acids,
which it's also a great for helping our hormone regulation,
feeding our gut microbiome,
which is important as well for hormone regulation,
which is also important for our immune system,
which affects our hormone regulation.
So all these things are linked.
Wait, you're saying it's all related?
I have, yeah.
I had Dr. B in here the other day,
going deep on fiber once again.
Yeah, of course.
Yeah.
And his whole thing about, eating 30 different plants
and setting that as a goal and the importance of fiber
for any number of things
and just how critical it is in this conversation.
It tends to get lost.
We focus on macronutrients or protein or,
or omega 3s, all of which are important, of course,
but most people are fiber deficient.
Like where's the, again, back to the low hanging fruit.
What is the quickest, easiest change that you could make
that could have the biggest impact?
And increasing the fiber in your diet
seems to have just a multiplicity
of downstream health benefits.
It does.
And there was a study.
I think it was actually led by Dr. Neil Bernard,
looking at how this could affect people and their periods.
And they had a two month cohort of women,
half were on a healthy plant-based diet.
The other half were a control group.
And they wanted to see, could it affect their periods.
And what they discovered was
that it did make a statistically significant difference
in the length and that the heaviness of the women's periods.
And also-
Just by increasing fiber.
Yep.
Wow.
Just by increasing fiber.
And it also showed raised SHBG,
sex hormone binding globulin, which is an important protein
that essentially holds on to hormones until we need them.
It's kind of like a storage molecule, if you like.
And what's interesting is it was able to increase that
for the women who are consuming a healthy plant-based diet,
which is important because that can help regulate their
unwanted hormone exposure as well.
And is that a function of just an increase in plant foods?
And by definition, an increase in fiber?
Or is there an aspect of that has to do
with the removal of the meat and dairy products?
It could be a bit of both.
So this is postulation-based.
So that study didn't say specifically why,
but we know that fiber is so crucial
for reducing, recycling of hormones, as I mentioned,
but also meat and dairy does have a role to play
with regard to hormone exposure itself.
So when we consume dairy,
we are consuming the milk from a cow who's been pregnant
and obviously is lactating, which has extra hormones,
bioequivalent hormones to human hormones.
But also in the meat that we eat,
there is some hormonal exposure there as well.
But also interestingly, I think,
is that meat is one of the main ways
that we get potential for microplastics exposures,
which are also affecting our hormones.
I think in the UK phthalates are highest in fish,
in the US, phthalates are highest in chicken.
And there is some data to show that there was an association
between increasing meat consumption
and increasing endometrial symptoms.
I'm not sure I even know what endometriosis is.
Okay so let's do a little backtrack.
Endometriosis is a condition
that could affect up to about 10% of women.
And it takes many years often to diagnose
because the women who are suffering from endometriosis,
just think that perhaps they've got really heavy periods,
but it's so much more than that.
So what it is where the womb lining tissue,
which normally just grows in the lining of the womb
and is shed once a month with your period,
starts to grow in other parts of the body.
We don't know why this happens.
It predominantly happens in the pelvis.
So you get that tissue that grows in the lining of the womb,
in other parts of the pelvis,
often sticking perhaps to bowel or to the bladder.
And but interestingly,
you can get endometrial deposits anywhere,
even in the brain, very rarely, or in the lungs.
And the problem is when you have your monthly bleed
those cells will also bleed.
And when they do, they cause irritation and inflammation.
So no matter where they are in the body,
they start to bleed?
Yeah.
Wow.
They will bleed.
And it can cross the blood-brain barrier?
Yeah.
Very rare.
But yeah, it's mostly around the pelvis or,
deposits perhaps on the outside of the womb.
But the problem is, that inflammation and irritation
then causes a lot of pain.
And it can cause parts of like the bladder
or the bowel to stick together.
It can affect fertility.
It can cause painful sex.
It's a really sort of far reaching condition.
And if women are suffering from horrendous period pains,
nausea, vomiting, have to take days off work,
painful sex problems, getting pregnant.
This is not normal.
And they have to go to the doctors
because many people will think,
"Oh, it's just my period."
But interestingly, periods can be really painful.
More painful than a heart attack, actually,
in some research tells us.
Wow.
That the pain of having a period,
because it's because of the prostaglandins
that are produced by those womb lining cells.
So when you're having a bleed,
these prostaglandins that cause contraction of the womb,
that's what causes the pain and the...
The cramping.
Those sort of feelings of nausea.
If the prostaglandins get into the bloodstream,
that's what causes you to have things like diarrhea,
and vomiting, nausea, it can get really bad.
And I think women, don't always sort of know
how to advocate for themselves.
People think, "Oh, it's just her period."
Well, actually for a lot of women, they really do suffer.
And especially when you have endometriosis,
which is a whole other condition related to your periods,
but causing so many more complications, so-
So it goes undiagnosed often
because people just think you're having
a severe period episode
or you're ignored and just consider to be normal?
Yeah, so either doctors will think,
"Oh, she's just having a heavy period.
I'll give her some painkillers."
Or she'll think, "Oh, I'm just having a heavy period.
I'll just have to wait a few days later, it'll be okay."
But for some women, it's completely life changing
and it can have a huge impact.
And as I say, up to 10% of women have this condition.
And is there a test for it?
And then once it's diagnosed, how is it treated?
So this is why it's hard to diagnose
because the main way of doing so is through a laparoscopy.
So you have to have an operation essentially
to see those deposits, which are usually in the pelvis.
Right, which no one's gonna do unless it's so severe.
Exactly.
So people will try and muddle through,
they might take some painkillers and hope for the best,
but actually it's really important to get that diagnosis
because once you have a diagnosis,
one of the main ways of treating it
is to actually kind of blast those little deposits,
burn them off,
and that can help to improve fertility and pain.
But I would love for women to know that diet and lifestyle
can have an effect on endometriosis as well,
a positive effect.
And having a healthy plant-rich diet
could improve symptoms greatly.
So yeah, I would love for,
if there's one message for this part of the podcast,
it would be for women who have endometriosis to know
that hopefully if they have a more plant-based diet,
they could see some improvement in their symptoms.
Interesting.
But they don't quite know what causes it,
and there isn't any kind of like simplistic cure?
No, there's no simplistic cure,
but I suspect that our extra hormone exposures
in the modern world play part,
just because, as I said, there's an association there
between the consumption of certain animal products
and the development of further endometrial deposits.
And we don't yet know,
I'd love for there to be more research.
It's the same with fibroids.
I would love there to be more research into fibroids.
Well, let's talk about that.
Define what fibroids are.
Okay.
So fibroids are essentially growths in the womb
and they are estrogen-independent.
So much like endometriosis,
which is in a way, fueled by estrogen exposures.
So is the development of fibroids.
And you can get extra painful periods,
again, with fibroids without realizing it.
So you'd be thinking, oh, I've just got a heavy period.
But actually the reason, that you've got it on this occasion
is because your fibroid mass, the lump,
is pushing against the womb lining,
which is causing it to increase in the surface area.
Then it bleeds more, than the period is heavier.
So not all fibroid lumps push into the womb lining.
Sometimes they can grow on the outside of the womb,
or in the middle of the womb,
but for the ones that push onto the womb lining,
they cause extra heavy bleeds.
And if the fibroids get big,
then they also have just a mass effect in the pelvis,
which can affect the way that you pee,
or the way that you're able to pass motions.
So it can have other downstream effects as well.
And again, I would really love to see more research
into the causation and amelioration of fibroids,
but suffice to say, in terms of lifestyle,
there are some things that we've seen
could be associated with it.
Again, we come back to the meat consumption
that can have an impact on the growth of fibroids,
perhaps because of the extra estrogens
or plastics that we're exposed too.
Alcohol is another one
that has been associated with fibroids.
Physical exercise has been something
that's potentially been associated
with less severe fibroids,
but we just have association data really.
So I'd like to see more of it.
And is there a test to know whether you have fibroids
or if you have them, you just know it?
You don't just know it unfortunately,
but you can get a scan.
It's much easier to diagnose fibroids-
because you can just,
you can arrange for an ultrasound scan,
and you'd be able to see those lumps there.
Sometimes with a scan,
you can see what could be endometrial deposits.
So if you have an unusual appearance to your ovaries,
it could be something called a chocolate cyst
because you get sort of dried old blood
then on the ovary itself,
which looks like sort of a dark cyst.
And you can sometimes see.
Because those cells have bled.
Because they've bled-
During period.
Yeah.
Wow.
Exactly.
So you can kind of get a hint of endometriosis
through a physical exam.
If your primary care physician
or your OB/GYN has done an internal exam,
you can sometimes get a feel
for whether the endometriosis there
based on whether the womb or the ovaries
feel fixed when you do an internal exam.
And you can again,
maybe get a hint of it with an ultrasound,
but the only way of truly diagnosing endometriosis
is with a laparoscopy.
But fibroids is much easier
because you only really need to scan.
And the appropriate lifestyle interventions
for fibroids look like what?
Well, I'd say really focus on whole foods,
healthy plant-rich diet, number one.
You'll be increasing your fiber.
So as I said before,
reducing your hormone exposure from your own body.
You'll be hopefully helping yourself
to potentially reduce any excess weight.
And you'll be avoiding xenoestrogens
from plastics exposures as well.
So that would be the main thing, I'd say.
Exercise is important.
Interestingly, there's some research to show
that certain things are great
for reducing the pain of periods,
which can affect endometriosis and fibroids.
So ginger and turmeric
have been shown in a couple of studies
to be really helpful in reducing
the amount of prostaglandins that are being produced
at the lining of the womb.
So I mean, essentially, if we kind of figure out,
this is why oral contraception could help periods actually,
because oral contraceptive pills reduce the amount
of endometrial lining cells that are produced,
which then reduces the prostaglandins,
which is what causes the pain and the cramping.
So yeah, so contraceptive pills can help with the pain.
Antiinflammatory painkillers can help with the pain
for the same reason, they reduce the prostaglandins.
But if we wanted to go sort of down a lifestyle route,
then ginger and turmeric have been shown in studies
to have the same benefits as anti-inflammatory painkillers
for reducing period pains.
So on some level, this is a disease of inflammation,
or a disease that's exacerbated by exposing the body
to inflammatory foods and environmental factors, right?
Yeah.
So it would follow logically
then that a diet that is anti-inflammatory in nature,
I mean, it's good for everything, right?
Would be particularly good at ameliorating those symptoms
of these conditions.
Yes, I think so.
And if we look at other hormonally driven things,
so not just endometriosis and fibroids,
but also polycystic ovaries,
again, it's another condition that affects fertility,
affects our periods,
but can also be improved using lifestyle.
Again, it's not something that tends to come up
in these kinds of conversations,
but PCOS, polycystic ovarian syndrome,
is very much like diabetes
in that it's driven by insulin resistance.
And insulin resistance can be improved
by using whole plant foods,
eating a much more whole few plant-based diet.
And so, yeah, that's another condition
that could potentially also be improved using lifestyle,
and have long reaching benefits.
Sure.
So increasing your fiber, turmeric, ginger,
what are some of the other anti-inflammatory foods
that top your list?
Well, we've gotta go for like berries, fruits, vegetables,
nuts, and seeds, tofu, tempeh.
I think soybeans have a terrible reputation still,
unfortunately, but they are really good
for hormone regulation.
Because not only do they contain
all essentially amino acids, but they also,
they contain a special kind of phytoestrogen,
which is actually beneficial.
So it's actually more of a modulator
rather than something that is an active
pusher of estrogen, if you like.
Right, so let's like really underscore that.
Because I think what happens is people hear soy,
they think estrogen,
you spoke earlier about dysregulated estrogen
causing these problems.
So without further inquiry,
it would appear that eating something like soy
with these estrogen compounds
would be not a good thing, right?
So like, I want you to be like really clear about soy,
estrogens, phytoestrogens the differences.
Okay. (chuckles)
soy contains phytoestrogens or estrogens,
but it's actually what we call a SER,
a selective estrogen receptor.
Right and if you're British, you say estrogen.
Yes sorry.
Keep going sorry to interrupt you.
(Gemma laughs)
My estrogen.
So it's selective in its action.
So what it does is,
if you are wanting to reduce your risk of breast cancer,
it's really great for that because it blocks the receptors
that are responsible for breast cancer.
If you want to improve your bone health,
it's actually really good for that
because it's more likely to selectively bind
to the receptors that are in the bone area of the body.
So it has selective effects, which are actually beneficial
in terms of our hormone exposures.
It stops us from being exposed to bioequivalent hormones,
and instead, blocks those.
So it's good for reducing risk of breast cancer.
Especially if you start to eat soy products young in life.
So for young girls, teenagers, young women,
there is some evidence to show
that if you have soy products in childhood and adolescents,
it's much more likely
to reduce your risk of breast cancer later in life.
But if you're a dude or a mate,
and you get on the soy early,
you become a soy boy and develop man boobs?
Well, you're probably more like to develop man boobs
if you drink actual cows milk, if you think about it,
'cause that's a bioequivalent estrogen,
but an actual fact there is data to show
that soy can potentially reduce the risk of prostate cancer.
(Rich gasps)
So you don't need to worry too much about soy.
All right.
Or in fact, you don't need to worry at all about soy.
Is there a difference between soy or tofu
versus like tempeh or a fermented soy?
I've always understood that a fermented version is better.
Yeah, I think there are different qualities, I suppose.
Interestingly, soy products have been shown
to be beneficial for flushes, sort of period flushes,
vasomotor symptoms in women.
So yeah, but in sort of Japanese populations,
they don't really have the same amount of flushing
and it's thought to be because they have a lot
of fermented soy products sort of meso and tempeh
and edamame beans.
And not that that's fermented,
but it's a more natural form of soy.
Yeah.
But yeah,
I think if you go for minimally processed sort of tofu,
tempeh, edamame beans, meso soup, that kind of thing.
Are you gonna have perhaps even better benefits, but yeah.
What about natto?
Have you had natto?
I've not had it, but I've heard it's disgusting.
I've heard that as well.
It's a top the list though, of like the most nutritious-
Yeah.
Fermented soy product.
And it's an acquired taste that they enjoy in Japan,
but is not necessarily readily available in the west.
No, I mean, yeah.
Maybe I'll try it one day, but I haven't tried it yet.
It's sort of the soy version of durian, right?
Like, but actually durian's delicious.
Yeah.
But it's an acquired...
I mean durian's a hardcore thing.
Yeah.
I mean the people that love it really love it.
It smells quite strong though, doesn't it?
Yeah, for sure.
But I actually wanted to say, before we get off the topic,
that interestingly, going back to The Gut Health MD
and his passion for the gut microbiome,
the effect of soy on flushes and things like that
can be affected by our microbiome or estrobolome.
So some people, unless we have the gut bugs
to sort of process the genestine from the isoflavone in soy,
we may not necessarily get the same flushing benefits,
which is why it's great
then to have an overall plant-rich diet,
because what you're doing there,
is you're promoting the kind of gut bugs
which would then hopefully be able to metabolize
the components of soy that benefit us
in terms of vasomotor flushing.
So if you have some form of dysbiosis,
that could be a causal factor
in a dysregulated hormonal state
and also a dysregulated period, right?
Or some kind of period issue.
Yeah, potentially.
So yeah, I'd say the bottom line is
that plants are always good in terms of hormone regulation.
And they can help to foster the microbiome
that could potentially then also use other parts of plants
to then benefit us.
When you're advocating a plant-based lifestyle,
how do you think about the difference
between a plant exclusive-diet
versus a plant-predominant diet?
As somebody who's seeing a lot of patients,
and for many, I suspect this is like a new idea.
How do you communicate around that?
And what is your kind of general position on that?
Yeah, my general position is I just want
people to eat more plants
and I don't tell my patients to go vegan
because I think we do have a lot of data
that you can have a very healthy plant rich diet
without necessarily going 100% vegan.
I am somebody that identifies as vegan,
but it's not something that I would say
my patients have to do.
I think that from what I've seen,
the more plants the better,
and we see that in the data as well.
The more plants we eat the better.
So it doesn't have to be plant exclusive,
but plant predominant is definitely
important for overall health.
And I just, you mentioned sort of low hanging fruit earlier.
That's kind of how I feel about it.
Right now, only 8% of what most of people
in the Western world eat is fruits and veggies.
It's more than 50% processed foods.
So if I can get people more on those fresh whole plant foods
and less on the processed foods, then that's a win.
So yeah, that's how I tend to advocate
for it at work with my patients,
because not, everybody's gonna feel 100%
ready to just dive in.
Yeah.
So yeah.
Have you had any patients come to you
who are on the carnivore diet?
I haven't, no.
Is that a thing in the UK?
Cause it's like quite a thing here in the states.
I know it's a big thing here
and it's getting more popular in the UK,
but if I'm honest, I've only really seen it in online
and in wellness circles rather than in my actual patients.
I think instinctively,
most people feel that having a meat exclusive diet
could cause long term issues. (laughs)
So.
How dare you?
I'm sorry to say, no, but I think, yeah,
it's not been something
that I've actually experienced in my patients,
but it's a tough one because in my practice,
I never like to say to people
that they're doing something that's wrong
because we all have different paths to health.
Having said that, it's really hard because
people sometimes feel great on a carnival diet to start
with they may have got rid of a lot of health issues
that they were having in the past.
And for me, I think that probably comes down
to a fairly strict exclusion diet.
You basically taking everything out,
which is fine for short term,
but it's not really something that you could
consider long term health.
Yeah that argument gets used against
the plant-based diet as well.
Like, oh, you feel better
when you went plant-based because you just
got off all the processed foods, but it's not sustainable.
And over time you're gonna be
nutrient mineral and vitamin deficient.
It's a shame that people say that about plant-based diets
because the way I see it based on the research is that
the plant-based diet is abundant in nutrients.
As long as you are choosing a large variety of fruits,
veggies, whole grains, beans, nuts, seeds, tofu,
tempe all of those incredible ingredients.
You're gonna get everything that you need except the B12.
But again, I think the health benefits that,
I've seen in my patients in the short term
and the long term and what we see in the data as well,
show us that a plant rich
and even a plant exclusive diet is brilliantly helpful.
What about the argument?
I'm sure you've seen this at least online
that plants are toxic, that they have toxins
that they've developed as natural defense mechanisms
and that makes them intolerable to the human body.
Have you heard that one?
I've heard that one online again, not with my patients.
I think it's, (laughs)
I think a lot of extreme ideas tend to come
from online spaces
and perhaps I don't know why that would be,
but I think if we look at the properties of plants,
yes they do have certain sort of phytonutrients
that we benefit from, but the toxins idea,
I think is actually something that is really damaging
because often it's those plant so-called toxins that
provide us with really important factors for our own health,
cause our bodies can use them in ways that actually help us
to support our microbiome and our immune systems.
So I think that's the difference between perhaps
mechanistic data and actually seeing what people do
in real life and seeing what they eat in real life
for longevity and health,
which are two sometimes completely opposed ideas.
When everything comes together,
when mechanistic data and observational data and randomized
control trials, all come together pointing to one direction,
we can feel a lot more confident.
Whereas if we're just looking at a single trial
or a mechanistic trial on an animal, for example,
we're not gonna really have the same picture.
Sorry to interrupt the flow.
We'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you
about the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know how
to eat better and aspire to incorporate more whole plants,
more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly however, without the kitchen tools
and support, very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet
transformed my life so profoundly
and because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced,
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised,
I'm proud to say is the Plant Power Meal Planner,
our affordable all-in-one digital platform that sets you up
for nutrition excellence by providing access
to thousands of highly customizable, super delicious
and easy to prepare plant-based recipes,
everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team of nutrition coaches,
seven days a week, and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up, visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now for a limited time,
we're offering $10 off an annual membership.
When you use the promo code RRHealth at checkout.
This is life changing stuff, people for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHealth for $10 off an annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
Let's talk about menopause.
So what is it and what can women do who are experiencing it?
Reduce the symptomology around it.
I'm actually really glad to talk about menopause
because I think it's something that many women feel
that they can't talk about.
It's weird, it's like this weird,
like it happens to every woman, right?
But it's this sort of not really shameful,
but like something that, oh, we just don't talk about it.
Yeah and I try to think about where that comes from.
I do think that we live in a patriarchal kind of society
that really values women for the way that they look
more than the way that they contribute to the world.
And I think a lot of women feel
that if they talk about menopause,
that their significance in the world is diminished somehow,
that their function to produce children is gone,
therefore their worth is gone.
That's something that I've noticed a lot,
certainly in my patients,
but also in general society that people feel really
reluctant to speak up about it and quite low about it.
Like it's something that, a lot of women feel
that they've lost something about themselves.
And I'd really like the conversation to change.
Because I think that if we can have an empowering idea
about what menopause can do,
then it can hopefully help women to actually feel
that they're even more contributing to the
world in ways that they couldn't do before.
There's only very few mammals that have a menopause.
This is really interesting.
There's three mammals that experience menopause,
obviously humans are one of them.
Do you have any idea what the other ones could be?
Well, I would think it would be chimpanzees or apes.
You'd think so.
But actually it's not.
Don't tell me it's dolphins.
Nearly, (laughs)
Whales.
It's yeah.
It's Orcas and pilot whales.
Wow.
Orcas, pilot, whales, and humans with the.
That's so bizarre.
I would've just presume that every mammal,
every female mammal experiences that.
No, and this is significant
because what it tells us I believe
is that we have a very specific purpose
past our reproductive years.
We have a very specific survival advantage in having
a menopause, whereas every other mammal does not.
And there's actually something called the grandmother
hypothesis, which essentially tries to explore this.
And the idea is that
the reason that humans have menopause is
because women in society have such value
in making sure that we continue as a species.
And we maybe look after younger children,
we would bring families together.
We would bring communities together.
There's a very strong survival advantage to having women
exist past their reproductive years.
And I think that should be celebrated
cause it's something very special, so yeah.
Yeah, the idea that evolution has prioritized this
because when the village expands
and there's more women around to care-take for
the many young ones, then everybody benefits as a result.
Everybody benefits and there's a survival advantage.
Think that would be the case with chimpanzees
and apes and all other manner of mammals as well.
Yeah, you'd think so.
But it's interesting because when you look at pilot whales
and orcas, they have a very matriarchal society,
don't they, they go around in matriarchal pods
and it's the grandmother that makes sure that
the mother and the babies are all together and protected.
So.
Right so we're off the rails here
being a patriarchal society.
Right, we are we're evolutionarily meant to be
a matriarchal society.
Okay.
I think so.
That's my hypothesis. (laughs)
Yeah, interesting.
So this occurs in every woman at a certain age
and the symptoms range and severity.
They do, and that's another interesting thing is the
symptoms can range in severity based on
where the woman lives in some to some degree.
So I mentioned Japanese women and vasomotor flashes.
That's one of the main symptoms for women certainly
in the US and the UK is hot flashes or flashes.
Whereas interestingly,
Japanese women don't tend to experience that.
There was some anthropology work done
in sort of two provinces of India
that showed that menopause brought about
increased quality of life in those women
because they were able to achieve more status.
They were able to spend more time with men.
They had more of a say in the household over the
sort of the sons and the wives and other younger children.
So in actual fact,
when they were sort of questionnaires to those women,
they had an increased quality of life
and far less menopausal symptoms than-
But what is the, I'm trying to understand
what that's attributable to the increase in quality of life?
I think that a lot of the symptoms of menopause
can be dreadful, but also that the society in which we live,
if it's more supportive to women going through menopause,
can dramatically reduce the effect on our lives.
So when you have a society that is supportive
or where the women is considered to be
a value, wise, contributing,
then it can be actually quite empowering
and it can hopefully potentially
lead to less in the way of symptoms.
That's not to say that it's all psychological.
No, there's some very physical and very real problems,
but I think it's important to just be aware that in society
and the way that we view women is really important
because it can affect our long term happiness.
It can affect the way that we feel
we can contribute to the world.
And that can also affect the symptoms that we experience
much with any kind of medical or health condition.
That's fascinating.
Yeah.
With the social environment and a supportive social
environment can have that kind of impact.
And it's-
Or it seems to appear that that's the case.
It seems to appear that way.
And it's true for all sorts of things.
There was a really interesting study that showed
that people who had increased happiness scores,
positivity, a good sense of humor.
Their longevity was increased even
when they were living with chronic disease.
So I think the importance of a supportive community
shouldn't be underestimated, which is why opening up
this kind of conversation is really
important so that men and women can understand how
to support the third of women that are right now,
peri or postmenopausal it's huge.
Sure.
So yeah.
I mean that dovetails into the blue zones discussion
and the importance of connectivity and community
and also of course like holistic health,
like how we think about these things,
which we can put a pin in, but sorry,
I interrupted you continue.
Yeah, no, well, I was just gonna sort of start talking
about some of the symptoms, which again,
are not that well known apart from the flashing
or the flashing.
Because women don't tend to talk about it too much.
But I've been married to Julie for over 20 years.
And I know about the occasional hot flashes,
but beyond that, I'm probably like a lot of guys,
I don't really know what's going on.
Yeah, it's okay.
But it's good that you can be more aware
and hopefully we can sort of expand on that now.
And all the men who listen to your podcast can hopefully.
I want to, yeah, this is about women's health,
but it's also about helping men understand these things
so that they can be more empathetic to their partners.
If they're in partnership with women
and learning how to communicate around it
in a positive manner.
It's true.
In fact, I think that Rod Stewart said
that if more men knew about menopause,
there'd be far less divorces. (laughs)
So do tell.
So I will.
So we've got the vasomotor flushes,
which can be really debilitating for some women
where you just have this tremendous heat
going through your body top to bottom,
sweat like crazy, tends to happen a lot at night as well,
but it can happen at any time of day.
Vaginal atrophy is a big one, and it doesn't just mean that,
you have soreness or some sort of dryness there.
It can actually be quite severe for some women.
So vaginal atrophy occurs
when your estrogen levels are going down
and it can cause painful sex and dryness,
but also it can cause severe burning, itching,
it can hurt to sit down.
It can, if you had an app episiotomy scar,
from when you were giving birth,
they can sort of come open.
They can split and bleed.
Like it can be a really severe problem.
That again is very little talked about,
but can really impact the quality of life.
Mood changes can be quite severe.
Increased anxiety is very real
and many women will put it down to, oh, I'm just depressed.
They may think that they need an antidepressant,
but actually it could be that the hormone changes
around menopause are responsible for some
of those changes in mood.
Body aches, this is a really interesting one.
Many women don't realize that severe bone
and muscle pain can be attributable
to those hormonal changes, up to 30%
of women going through menopause get body aches,
but they won't always attributed
to those changes in hormones,
which is another big one, dry skin, dry eyes.
Some women only experience severe dry eyes,
which can again be very debilitating.
We're having to use drops, not being able to see properly.
It can actually really impact quality of life as well.
Low libido, your sex drive can sometimes go down.
Understandably, if you have vaginal atrophy,
but sometimes there are other things attached to that
as well, with regard to identity
and feeling of worth and attractiveness to your partner,
that there's all sorts of other things
that can sort of play a role there.
So yeah, there's quite a lot of different symptoms.
You are more likely to get constipated
because there are estrogen receptors that are in the gut.
So you have reduced gut motility,
which then has an impact on, again,
your hormone regulation.
Because of the lack of estrogen,
your body tries to come back to balance.
And so you get metabolic changes as well
in the Western world, about 65% of women have obesity
because of the way that the fat deposits more
around sort of the center of the body as a
way of trying to compensate for the lower estrogen
that's being produced by the ovaries.
because as we talked about earlier,
fat cells can produce estrogen.
So again, these are things
that a lot of women don't necessarily realize
are related to those changes in hormones.
Bone loss, so unfortunately from about 40 onwards
we'll lose about half percent of our bone mineral density.
But when you go through menopause that drops precipitously,
many women will lose about 20% of their bone mineral density
in the first five to seven years after menopause.
Wow.
And that causes you increased risk, significant fractures.
Yeah, that's very significant.
Yeah, it's really significant.
So I think that this is a public health issue,
and I think that if more women knew
that the time around menopause can be a time of empowerment,
then they could actually potentially
prevent further problems.
So HRT or HRT is something that, again,
we don't tend to talk much about, but is a.
Hormone replacement therapy.
It's a really important thing to open up a conversation
around because it's one of the number one
treatments to ameliorate a lot of these symptoms in women
who are eligible and who want to.
And including things like bone, mineral, density, loss,
and heart disease risk as well.
And I think there's a lost generation of women
who felt that it was too dangerous to even consider HRT.
And in those women, I think
there's a huge injustice that has been done there
because HRT as a hormone replacement model
is a great way to ease that hormonal transition.
Rather than going through all those fluctuations,
you are replacing a lot of the hormones
that you would've otherwise lost,
and you are maintaining your bone mineral density.
You can improve a lot of the bone ache issues.
You're actually reducing potentially your
risk of heart disease as well.
But there is a window of opportunity with regard
to heart disease risk.
And that's like around the menopause,
if you're within 10 years of menopause
or less than the age of 60,
that would be a good time to
reduce your risk of heart disease moving on in life.
And the same with the bone mineral density loss.
There's that window of opportunity there in that
sort of five to 10 year window between sort of 45, 55,
where if you are eligible,
it's worth at least exploring the idea of HRT.
Okay so with that in mind then, what,
wait, hold on a second,
let me collect my thoughts before I start.
We were talking about HRT, right?
Right.
So with that in mind,
how safe or unsafe is HRT in general now,
and what are the factors that determine
whether a woman is a good candidate for this?
So there will be certain women that are
not eligible for HRT.
Primarily those who've experienced breast cancer,
but there are other potential reasons
why they wouldn't want to have HRT as well,
obvious things like pregnancy or a recent blood clot
or an undiagnosed bleed, for example.
But in actual fact, I would say excluding those women,
most women would be pretty good candidates for HRT.
The main problem that really scared a lot of women
back in sort of 2002
was the women's health initiative study,
which showed that there was potential increased
risk of breast cancer.
In fact, the study was halted early
over concerns about excess breast cancer risk.
And unfortunately the headlines around that study
went around the globe
and made the use of HRT drop by about 66%.
In other words, the headlines being something
along the lines of HRT will cause breast cancer.
Yeah, exactly.
And it scared everyone.
It scared doctors. It scared women who were taking HRT.
So many women stopped taking it.
But interestingly, Professor Langa
who was one of the main investigators as part of the study,
wrote a paper condemning the headline of the study
as being irresponsible and wholly inaccurate.
And many of the lead investigators on that study
were not consulted before it was even published.
And one of the main problems with the study
was that they used women aged 65 or thereabouts,
and they were starting HRT brand new.
And of course by that stage,
a lot of those risk factors for breast cancer
and excess risk of heart disease, for example,
were already in existence before they began the treatment.
And I do believe it's let down a whole generation of women.
There was a really interesting study in the BMJ from 2012
that showed that if you take HRT for a period of five years,
you actually have reduced risk
of heart attacks and heart failure.
There was no increased risk of breast cancer
or blood clots at all.
And there was an interesting study by David Katz
actually in 2013.
And he estimated that in the 20 years after 2002,
that there were anywhere between
around 20,000 to 90,000 women
who died prematurely from not having access to HRT.
Wow.
Because of the protection it can offer
for heart disease and bone mineral density loss,
as well as obviously all of the other symptoms
that we've talked about
with the flushing and the mood changes
and the way the vaginal atrophy
and the way that these things can impact
their lives day to day.
And the optimal time to begin HRT
would be early in menopause right
before you've already suffered bone loss
and all these other ramifications.
Yeah, and the age of menopause does vary.
The average age is about 51,
but it's normal for it to start anywhere
between ages sort of 45 to 55.
And I think that it's actually vital to think about
if you're going to think about starting it then,
because you are preventing, it's a prevention, isn't it?
So you're preventing the bone mineral density loss.
You're preventing the atherosclerotic plaques
that we start forming
because of the lack of estrogen in the body and
how that's cardioprotective.
And it's a way of then essentially lengthening your time
where you are sort of functional
and you're not having some of these problems.
And what is the composition like,
what is the hormonal composition of HRT?
So it is basically a combination
of estrogen and progesterone.
Interestingly, if you have estrogen-only HRT,
then there's absolutely no excess risk
of breast cancer at all.
But the reason that progesterone is often added is to help
protect the womb lining because if you have a normal womb
and you just give unopposed oral estrogen,
then you could have excess risk of bleeding
and increased risk of endometrial cancer,
which is why progesterone is given in combination
with the estrogen replacement.
But if you look at the,
there's loads of different types and formulations of HRT,
but I do wanna stress that if you're going
for like the gold standard,
which would be an estrogen gel or an estrogen patch
alongside micronized progesterone,
then taking that for about five years,
there was a systematic review to say that there was
absolutely no increased risk of breast cancer at all.
So I'd love for women to know that.
If they want to look into it, they should.
It comes, as I say, in the form of patches, gels, tablets.
And yeah, there's loads of different brands,
but essentially it's just estrogen and progestogen.
And what percentage of women currently are on HRT?
Is it a low percentage?
It's low and it's increasing gradually.
I think it was probably at its lowest
just after the 2002 study.
It's gradually creeping up with a lot more awareness now
about menopause and the symptoms, especially in the UK.
I dunno if that's translated over here in such
a big way, but I get lots more women coming to me
in clinic asking about HRT, which I'm really pleased about
because so many women over the years are said,
"Oh, it's not natural, it's not for me.
And it's harmful, I'm worried about breast cancer."
And I want women to know that it's a very valid option
and it's actually, the menopause guidelines suggests
that it's the number one treatment
for bone mineral density loss, as I mentioned.
Wow, yeah, you mentioned the word natural.
There is an interesting thing within wellness
and holistic health circles
that obviously are gonna prioritize natural remedies.
Food as medicine, et cetera,
at the cost of medical interventions that could be helpful.
So there's a weird in the Venn Diagram
between evidence-based medicine
and lifestyle protocols and the kind of organic wellness,
alternative holistic health,
I could see attention between those two things like somebody
who's like, well, I'm just gonna eat organic food.
You're saying yes,
but this intervention could be beneficial,
but Hey, that's not really part of my protocol.
I'm trying to not be on any kind of exogenous interventions.
Yeah and that's something that I respect.
If someone doesn't want to take extra hormones,
then they shouldn't have to.
And I completely understand that perspective.
I think what bothers me is the idea that the choice of women
is often taken away because of unfounded fears.
And I think for me,
it's important to be able to offer something that could
benefit and whether women want to have it
or not is up to them,
but we have to consider what's really natural,
I guess, in the environment that we're currently living in.
You could say it's natural to die in childbirth
because if you are in Afghanistan
and you're in a village somewhere,
you've got about a one in 14 chance of dying
from childbirth, is that natural or yes,
I suppose it is, but it's clearly not something
that anybody would wish to happen.
And so I think when it comes to severe menopausal symptoms,
but also longevity,
I wanna be able to provide women with every possible option
that is deemed to be healthy and appropriate.
And if they wanna take it, they can.
You mentioned earlier that the age at which
young women are experiencing their period
is getting earlier and earlier.
Is there also a change in the window for menopause?
Is that happening earlier also?
No so I think it may be again,
a reflection of Western society and the various exposures
that we have, but menopause in some cultures
is actually seemingly getting a bit later.
There is some potential genetic differences as well,
Afro-American women will potentially,
African, or should I say,
I dunno what you say here, African American.
African American, black women.
There are some potential genetic differences
in when you would start the menopause anyway.
So for example,
black women may find that they start their periods
on average about 48, 49,
whereas white women may start on average about 50, 51.
But yeah, I think menopause can vary based on diet as well.
There was an interesting study to show
that eating more vegetables
could potentially bring the age of menopause
slightly younger, again,
not dramatically like maybe three months on average
when were looking at sort of large population data.
But I think that that's very interesting, cause again,
it speaks to the effect that our diets can have
on our normal physiological processes.
Is there a mode of eating or particular foods
that could lessen some of the
negative symptomology around it?
Absolutely and I'd say again,
I'm gonna bang on about fiber.
Fiber is crucial and soy, minimally processed soy products
are really beneficial as well,
making sure that you have a nice variety
of things like nuts and seeds for extra minerals,
like selenium are important.
Even sort of things like I know we haven't
touched on thyroid function, but again,
that's another hormonally regulated organ
you wanna be able to make sure that you're having
great sources of iodine, selenium, zinc.
And that's true for all of the hormones in the body,
but especially things like the thyroid.
And what are some of your favorite foods
that are high in those things?
So with selenium,
you could just have like a Brazil nut a day, Brazil nuts.
That would be pretty good, but it's also in whole grains,
whole grain rice, whole grain bread,
other nuts and seeds and the same with zinc as well,
which again is important for things like sperm production.
I know we're not talking about men, but sperm.
We're gonna get to that.
Yeah, so there are loads of great foods.
So just think fruits, veggies, whole grains,
beans, soy products, I'm a big fan of flaxseeds
just because they're great at helping to improve
the suppleness of blood vessels.
And yeah, they've got loads of great omega 3s
from plant sources as well.
Just make sure you grind them first grind.
Otherwise they pass right through.
Exactly.
Let's talk about male hormonal health
is man-opause like a real thing?
And also I'm interested in your thoughts
on TRT cause it's obviously the other side of that coin.
Yeah, so I think that for men, I mean,
I don't have personal experience of this,
but certainly with my patients,
it doesn't seem to be as much of a thing
for men as for women.
And I mentioned earlier,
I think it's because it's a very gradual decline.
Like with most of the hormones in our body,
testosterone production can start to wane over time.
So I think in certain conditions
it might be beneficial for testosterone replacement,
but I don't see it as being something
as vital for male health
as estrogen replacement would be for female health
based on the changes in the body that occur for women
that just simply don't occur for men.
I know so many guys my age
that are on testosterone therapy,
I'm not, but they talk about it.
It's something that guys of my age tend to,
"Are you doing that?
Should I do that, should I not do that?"
Are there negative health outcomes with respect to that?
My understanding is that if you get on it,
then that's it, you have to stay on it because obviously
if you're taking it exogenously,
then it's gonna shut down your body's
whatever your body is making, right?
Like it's telling your body,
like you don't need to make any of this
because you're getting it.
I think this is where men should be cautious
and speak to their own doctors about whether
it's necessary or not.
Especially if you are somebody that is actually hoping
to perhaps further a child at any time,
because like you say,
you are turning off your own testosterone production there,
whatever it is still going on
and that can have ramifications for your fertility.
So I think that probably be the main consideration
depending on the intentions of the person
that wants to take testosterone replacement,
just to think carefully about
if it could actually impact their fertility.
But yeah.
I think most guys, my age are pro are,
they're not worried about that part.
Probably actually they want the opposite. (laughs)
Not everyone, but.
Yeah so yeah it's not something
that is as prevalent or indeed
I don't believe is necessary for men as it is for women,
but it's a conversation that I think is occurring
a lot more in-
Wellness what would be the reason for doing it?
Probably to increase things like muscle mass, mood changes
sometimes that can occur in men as the testosterone levels
that you're endogenously producing fall.
I think one of the main reasons that my patients
would go on testosterone replacement
is if they have excess estrogen exposures.
So it tends to happen more
when men are carrying excess weight as well.
That because as I mentioned before,
the fat cells can produce estrogen,
which can have perhaps a slight feminizing effect.
So yeah.
What else is unique to male hormone health
that you can speak to?
I think one of the main things that is worth talking about
for male hormone health is the gradual decline
or the gradual apparent decline in sperm counts
over the course of the last couple of generations
and the increased rates
of something called hypospadias which is where the urethra,
the wee tube, sort of forms and grows
on the underside of the penis
and the increased rates of
only having one testicle at birth.
This is something that I suspect is related to, again,
the plastics exposures in our environment,
the phthalate exposures, and that-
I didn't know that was a thing.
An increase in men being born with one testicle.
Yep what percentage of the population?
I don't know the percent.
Significant enough that it's-
It's been noted to be increasing.
Wow.
And again, as I said, the hypospadias issue as well,
where there's a sort of a distortion to the penis as a
result of changes in the exposures in the womb, basically,
'cause obviously this is the way
that the baby has been born.
And yeah, I do see that there is a correlation there
between that and increased rates of exposure
to things like microplastics, phthalates, BPA,
and it can potentially affect sperm counts too.
So simple things that I think men could do
that would be useful would be,
studies are shown that vigorous exercise
is quite good for sperm count,
assuming that you're not putting too much excess heat
on the testicles themselves.
Because like for example, with cycling or hot baths,
cause that can have an impact on the sperm production.
Otherwise vigorous exercise is good.
Sources of zinc and selenium, as I mentioned,
things like nuts and seeds are really helpful.
Co enzyme Q10, again,
that can come through those kinds of healthy foods,
nuts, seeds, whole grains.
And minimizing plastics exposures generally,
which I think probably the low hanging fruit
would be to drink your water from glass rather than plastic
to avoid something that's come in a plastic bottle.
If it's been sitting in the heat like in your car,
if it's a hot day, for example.
And you don't know,
it could be in a cooler in the grocery store,
but it had to be transported from somewhere.
It could have been on a truck for days or weeks.
That's true.
Excruciating heat.
We just don't know.
Getting rid of plastic.
It's so hard.
It's so completely ubiquitous.
It's crazy.
And I say it's almost impossible.
I think recently there was a study to show that it's been
microplastics have been found in the human bloodstream.
It's something that we can't escape at this point,
but we can minimize.
And I don't want people to come away from this conversation
feeling scared I think I'd rather,
they feel empowered to know there's a few things
that we can do to minimize our overall exposure.
And that would be heating,
if we are using a microwave, for example,
then just put it in ceramic or in glass as you heat it.
If you are drinking water, drink it from a bottle maybe.
If you can invest in a water filter, do so.
Simple things that hopefully
will over years accrue to benefits.
What about the role of dietary fats and hormone health?
Yeah interestingly I have read data
to say that saturated fat consumption
has been associated with lower sperm counts in men.
So that's something of interest.
We also know that when you are eating
a high saturated fat diet,
then it tends to be mostly from animal products.
And again, you've got those extra plastics exposure,
things that can affect hormonal health from there.
So it's hard to necessarily separate the two.
But in a more general sense,
we have lots of data to show that a saturated fat rich diet
is very linked to things like heart disease
and public health campaigns can make a difference.
So I know that there, may be listeners that think, oh,
well you're only feeling better
because you're eating more whole foods
and it's fine to have things like grass-fed beef and so on.
But if you look at data from countries like Finland,
for example, they had the highest rates
of heart disease in the world
back in the 1970s, they wanted to do something about it.
They had a massive public health campaign.
Many people reduced their red meat consumption,
stopped smoking, eight more vegetables.
And then moving fast forward about 20, 30 years,
they've managed to reduce the heart disease rates by 80%.
So we can see that these basic simple things that people
can do that can have tremendous impacts
on our health moving forwards.
Right.
Within the whole food plant-based community,
there's varying opinions about
the positive or negative consequences of fats in the diet.
We have the Caldwell Esselstyn camp,
which is very low fat, no oils.
Typically that protocol
is something that's advised for people
that are experiencing heart disease
or have suffered some sort of atherosclerotic event.
And then there's another camp of people
who are saying that's hyperbole,
a healthy dose of olive oil in your diet is fine.
Like how do you come down on this hot debate?
It's very divisive.
It is divisive and I hate divisive debates. (laughs)
So I try and stay out of them.
I dunno if you noticed,
but I don't tend to get into it online.
Well, I'm gonna put you square in the middle
of it right now.
You're gonna have to state your position.
Okay so my position is we have to eat more veggies,
as I mentioned before, that's the number one.
You're dodging, that's a dodge if I ever heard one.
Looking at the data that we have,
I think it's fair to say that if you are having good quality
olive oil with polyphenols in it,
can have some health benefits.
I don't think that having olive oil in your diet is
an unhealthy thing to do.
And I think a generally Mediterranean style of diet is known
by many people,
many nutrition researchers to be one of the best ways
of eating for overall health, which includes olive oil.
Yeah, I don't think that for the majority of people
having oil here and there is going to be at all harmful,
I'm not somebody that thinks that seed oils
are particularly harmful either
because they are rich in PUFAs and MUFAs,
polyunsaturated fatty acids, mono unsaturated fatty acids,
which we know are beneficial to health
if you are replacing saturated fats in the diet
with those kinds of oils.
So yeah, I think
it's hard to sort of come down hard and fast,
but I'd say looking at the data that we have
trying to compare, one thing to another,
seed oils have no demonstrable issues
when it comes to heart health.
But I would say that if you are aiming to lose weight,
then it's not a great idea to have a lot of things
like seed oils in your diet because they're very calorific
and they don't really contain a lot
in terms of the nutrients
that you'd be looking at to help fill you up
like the fiber-rich foods would.
And also I have a certain cohort of patients,
certainly that notice
when they have a lot of oils in the diet
that it can flare up things like inflammatory arthritis.
And I think it would be remiss of me to avoid mentioning
that certain people who have a whole food plant-based,
no-oil diet find that it's beneficial for inflammatory
arthritis as well as potentially beneficial
for heart disease.
And I would assume there's a difference
between raw olive oil that you sprinkle on a salad
versus cooking with it,
like the oxidative impact of high heat
on some of these oils.
That's a whole different thing.
It is.
Although I would say that the heat at which most people cook
at home is not gonna cause too much oxidation of olive oil.
I think that's something that's probably overstated.
Do what is the oxidation temperature point?
Do you know?
I don't remember Rich, you put me on the spot there.
I stumped you.
Yeah.
I'd have to look that one up
I know that, well every oil has a different-
Smoke point.
Smoke point, right?
So coconut oil is much higher.
It is.
It doesn't oxidize until you get super hot.
So it's sort of advised that if you're gonna cook with one,
that's the one to cook with.
Well, that depends
because coconut oil also contains saturated fat,
which is still saturated fat,
even though it comes from a plant.
So I think if someone wants to
concern themselves with the smoke point,
then avocado oil is probably a good choice
or cold pressed canola oil would be a good choice as well.
That's always been the one, the number one enemy one.
Sorry, but the data suggests
that cold press canola oil is
a pretty good oil to cook with because it contains
the unsaturated fats and it has a higher smoke point.
So yeah.
Well, if you don't wanna cook with it, you don't have to.
Controversy.
(laughs)
In the daily practice of being a doctor
and seeing patients,
what do you find to be when you're in this discussion
around changing your lifestyle,
maybe adopting a more plant predominant diet,
and then following up with these people,
what do you find to be the common blind spots
or stumbling blocks or places where people can go astray?
I think our food environment is probably
the biggest thing.
So we seem to have this feeling in the wellness space,
that we are all individuals and unique
and we can make choices that are not unrelated
to other things in the world.
And actually most of the choices we make around food
are unconscious choices about,
I think UCL research stated that there was over 200
unconscious food choices that we make every day
and only about 13 to 15 conscious food choices.
Wow.
When I didn't know that we made that many food choices
in a day period.
Well exactly, but that's what fascinates me is to think
when the research tells us that
so many of the factors that control what we eat
are actually out of our conscious mind,
it's much harder than to make changes for the long term
that are healthy,
especially if you don't have the mental bandwidth
or the budget to think about these things.
Having said that, we know that whole plant foods
can be some of the cheapest things
you can buy as long as you can get access to them.
So one of the main stumbling blocks for me
has always been people's habits
and ability to have the bandwidth to make
those changes mentally.
So I really start simple, just go for very simple swaps,
find their favorite meals and make them with more plants.
Basically, maybe get them to write down
the favorite things that they
like to cook and add more beans,
add more lentils, add more vegetables,
and then gradually crowd out the other things
has been one of my number one sort of ways
to get people to eat more veggies.
I feel like it's two main things.
One which you just refer to,
which has a lot to do with being more conscious about
the environment that you keep.
If you can create an environment
where the healthy choice is the most convenient,
because you've cleared all the bullshit out of your cabinets
and you only have healthy choices.
And when you wake up in the middle of the night,
sorry it's gonna happen,
you've got the much, you get your carrot, right?
You know that Ben and Jerry's just ain't there.
So it's about a conducive environment
to making the better choice.
But I think perhaps even the bigger issue
and stumbling block is really the social issue.
People get all up in their heads
about what other people are gonna think about them.
What's gonna happen when they go to Susie and Dave's
dinner party and they don't wanna make a fuss,
or I have to go on vacation with my neighbors
and it's just gonna be too problematic.
And people like relinquish their boundaries
or are just too afraid to stand up for themselves
or to like make that conscious choice
because they don't want to be difficult.
Yeah, I can totally relate
to that because that was my instinct first of all,
when I started on this journey.
My main thought was, oh,
this is gonna be so awkward for everybody.
People are gonna think this is so strange.
I think as social creatures,
it's one of the main considerations
that a lot of people have.
And I guess it comes down to
living in alignment with the things that you most want.
And do you most want to be somebody that pleases others?
Do you most want to be somebody that lives in alignment
with things that are important to you?
Are those things one and the same?
If you can have a conversation with yourself
around the values that you are living by,
it becomes much easier to then make conscious choices
that are in alignment to those values.
So I would actually encourage everybody
to have this conversation with their loved ones
or even just with themselves.
They could write it down in a journal,
write down their top values in life
and how their food choices can relate to those values.
And then it becomes a lot easier because you're taking away
a lot of the extra choices that you're having to make,
or the social situations that you're having to navigate,
because you are consciously living in alignment
with the things that matter.
So if it matters to you to minimize your risk of heart
disease, because you have a relative that died young,
you wanna see your children grow up.
Then you write that down and you find ways
to make it work within that kind of framework
if you like your values framework.
If animal compassion is important to you,
it's probably a lot easier because you've already made
that decision for another outside purpose.
It's something that's outside of yourself.
And perhaps the same can be true for someone
that cares deeply about the environment and the planet.
They've already made that decision based on a value
that's so strong to them that it actually
makes it a little bit easier to stick to.
I think health overall is probably one of the first ways
people go towards plant-based nutrition,
but it's also one of the hardest ways to stick with it
if that's your only goal, because it's quite self focused.
Whereas if you can focus on something outside of self,
then it potentially could make those choices a lot easier.
Either environmental health or animal compassion or reasons
to stay healthy for others.
It tends to be in my experience ways
that make it stick a lot more.
That's a really good way of thinking about it.
One of the questions that I get all the time,
I'm sure you do as well is I want to do this,
but my partner doesn't want any part of it.
And you began on this journey.
Richard was doing it ahead of you
two different dinners meals, et cetera.
But for a lot of couples, that becomes very problematic,
especially when those values might come
into conflict with each other.
Yes, you're so right.
And I think my advice from that being
the partner that was most reluctant,
perhaps I can speak to this more.
If the idea that what I needed was patience and time.
And sometimes people will never come around.
Sometimes the people you love the most will never want to do
the things that are important to you when it comes to diet.
And I think that taking away that expectation is important
because when you start to expect things of other people,
that's where you can start to become very unhappy.
It builds kind of criticism in your mind.
It builds comparison. It builds expectation.
And that can be quite toxic for your relationship.
So my best advice is just to
do the thing that's making you happy,
do the thing that brings you in alignment
with who you want to be
and show your partner through your actions,
how much happier, how much healthier,
and how much more abundant you feel in your life.
And then if they wanna come along for the ride, they can.
Right but you have to be detached from that expectation.
Otherwise you're gonna be vibing them all the time.
And then that piousness creeps up
and then it just becomes a disaster.
Exactly, you've gotta let that go. (laughs)
You just gotta let that go.
Even if it's in the back.
Well, if I keep doing this, they'll eventually come around.
It's no, you gotta like get rid of that.
I do think that that's probably the best way for you
to sustain a healthy relationship with the people
that you love the most.
And it's hard because often the people you love the most
may you feel, need it the most,
especially if they have a health condition
that could benefit from doing that.
But you have to let it go because it's not your life.
It's their life.
Right, that's advice for this particular scenario,
but for a zillion others as well,
like in terms of like partnership dynamics.
And in a partnership,
you will often have expectations of a partner
that are unspoken.
And that could be true for any kind of scenario.
And that's not to say that you shouldn't communicate the
things that are important to you.
Of course you should.
But it's the expectation that is attached to that,
which I think can become very negative in the relationship.
So letting go of the expectations of your partner
is probably the key to a happier life in all sorts of ways.
Did Richard do that?
Yeah, he was very patient with me. (laughs)
In fact, when at one point I think cause
steak used to be my favorite meal and burgers.
I'd always all order burgers when I was out and steak,
I loved steak.
And once he even cooked a steak for me,
that shows much he loves me.
Oh, it's strategic.
Yeah, exactly.
It's like reverse psychology.
Right, so it was in the back.
"Oh, if I do this." Right, who knows?
But that brings up an important issue,
which is somebody who's listening to this
or watching it is thinking, well, my life is just gonna
become infinitely more complicated.
It means like we're gonna have
to prepare two different meals.
I'm gonna have to spend all this time in the kitchen.
I'm gonna have to plan out everything in advance.
It's probably gonna be expensive and suddenly my life,
which was kind of going along pretty good,
suddenly gets hijacked by this new lifestyle habit that is
gonna commander all my time, energy and money.
And is that the person that's wanting to start this?
Or is this the partner of the person that's
wanting to start this?
It's the plant curious person
who's contemplating the change,
but now suddenly feels like maybe
this is a little bit too difficult.
So it's kind of moving from contemplation to action
that people tend to have a stumbling block.
Well, they're hearing you and they're like,
my partner's not gonna be into this.
So am I willing to
Rock the boat?
Yeah, do this thing
that's gonna potentially cause fissures
in my relationship and take up a lot of my time.
Yeah, and those are valid, very valid concerns.
And I guess what I'd say to that person is
you have to find the thing that helps you know
where you are going for the future.
I think a lot of the time we kind of
coast through and we do things
because they are the path of least resistance.
And sometimes the path of least resistance is a great path
and it works and everything's going well.
But sometimes over the course of maybe weeks,
months to years, we start to notice actually,
this isn't really working for me anymore.
Although this is the easier route, I'm not feeling this.
I either don't feel healthy or there's something niggling me
in my conscience about things I wanna do differently.
And sometimes changes do require
a certain amount of forward thinking.
And sometimes the biggest changes that we make in our lives
are as a result of pain points,
things that come up in our lives that we don't like.
Hello.
(laughs)
Exactly, pain can be our biggest teacher.
And for those who are hoping to start making changes,
but that pain point isn't quite there yet,
then maybe they won't make a change.
Maybe this won't be the right time for them.
But my hope is that if we plant these seeds together today,
some people will have enough water to plant
to water those seeds.
And other people may have enough sunlight to provide those
seeds with a little bit of sunshine.
And maybe those seeds will grow into plants of change.
Based on today.
So the person who's sticking that seed into the soil
right now and getting ready to water it,
but doesn't know how to water it.
Like how do you think about the early phases of this?
I'm somebody who went all in.
That's just my personality type.
I recognize most people aren't like that.
I suspect you're somebody who would counsel people to make
tiny changes, master them.
Like how do you get somebody engaged in this
and give them some actionable advice
about how to begin in a very practical manner?
So number one is literally write down the foods
that you buy in your weekly shop.
Number two is write down all the foods
that you make with those ingredients.
And if you can find one meal a week
that you'd like to have more plants in,
then that can be your first step is literally just cook one
meal a week that is plant-based and see how you feel.
And then if that works for you,
then you can cook another one
and then maybe cook another one.
Yeah, but all I do is eat takeout.
(laughs) Well, if you eat takeout then
interestingly in the US,
I dunno if it's the same, but in the UK
we have a, pretty good plant-based ready meal range
in a lot of our supermarkets.
And interestingly, I had a patient
who was elderly type two diabetic, never cooked for himself.
And I said to him,
why don't you just swap that one ready meal
that you buy for this ready meal,
which has all plants in it and in doing so he was able
to come off insulin and improve his type two diabetes.
So there's always a starting point for everybody.
If you're somebody that just eats takeout,
then you know what for you,
the best thing would be perhaps just to start with one home
cook meal a week, rather than trying to change everything,
just cook one meal at home,
rather than having all meals takeout.
For my elderly patient who was just eating like
small ready meals from the supermarket,
switch to a plant-based one and see how you feel,
see if it changes your health over time.
So it's just,
it is for a lot of people about those baby steps.
For others, like you, they jump in and they'll get started
and they'll figure it out along the way
and they'll enjoy that process, and that's great.
But for most people it's just little steps
and there was research by BJ Fogg to show that only
one change is enough to then start changing that,
shifting that identity and then sort of adding
in something new after that.
So yeah just one thing,
one thing is all you need to do.
I'm getting BJ Fogg in here.
I've been going back and forth with him on email forever.
He's getting in here soon though.
Yeah, I like that idea.
I think in listening to you, I'm reflecting on,
some of my habits now and what I find myself doing from
time to time when I'm busy or Julie's outta town
or she's I'm not cooking tonight.
I go get plant-based takeout,
but you have to be really careful
because when you're getting takeout food,
you're not preparing the food,
there's gonna be more oil in it than you think,
there's gonna be more salt in it than you think.
And if you're opting for some of these meat and dairy
analogs, like maybe not so good, not all of 'them
they're all, it depends on what.
It does.
Because there's a spectrum, and in terms of health
the health factors that are what these things are about,
but how do you think about the Beyond Burgers
and the Impossible Burgers and all of that kind of stuff.
I like to be fairly practical in the advice
I give to people.
I think if somebody likes the taste of an Impossible
or Beyond Burger and wants to have it once or twice a week,
then there's no reason why they shouldn't
for the most part, especially early-
Exactly.
In the transition.
But then having said that,
there is interesting data emerging
that there was a study that one of my friends did actually
on a specific brand of plant-based
meat replacement, meatballs and mince.
And in the study,
families were given these meat replacements to use alongside
the normal meat and other foods that they would prepare.
And what they found is that in the families
that had the meat replacement,
they had a favorable change in their microbiome
over the course of those.
I don't remember how many weeks the study was,
but it was perhaps about four weeks to my recollection.
They had really great shifts in their microbial health
from using meat replacement analogs.
So I think we do need more research to understand the effect
on the body, but we do also know
for in the majority of these meat replacement analogs,
there will be less saturated fat.
There will be less or no heme iron,
which are both potential issues
when it comes to heart disease,
risk and inflammation in the body.
And I think they are too easily demonized
by a lot of people.
And yeah, that's my take on it.
I wouldn't say you should have them every day.
But it's the same with any kind of food.
It's great to have variety and whole foods
as your main go-to.
But I think a lot of people are too quick
to cast off these meat replacements.
Right, yeah.
Well, again, it's a spectrum, some are worse than others.
And there's a difference between health promoting
and neutral versus deleterious to your health.
Exactly.
I think what is becoming a bigger issue over time
is that now there are so many products out there
that taste really good
and you can kind of psychologically rationalize
eating them like, oh, it's vegan, it's plant-based.
Like it's gotta be good for me, right?
And wake up only to realize like,
you're eating French fries and Beyond Burgers all the time.
That's not a whole food plant-based diet.
And it becomes incumbent upon you to like really make sure
that you're eating plant foods close to their natural state
as wide a diversity as possible
rather than diluting yourself
that because you're not eating cheeseburgers,
you're eating a plant version of that,
so you're gonna sidestep heart disease, right.
Yeah, exactly.
It's hard.
It's kind of like the stuff finally tastes good
for the most part
and it's gonna continue to get better and better and better.
I think what we're gonna see is like a split.
We're gonna have foods
that are gonna taste exactly like that thing,
but they're gonna be probably on the more unhealthy side.
And then there's gonna be other companies who are creating
plant analogs to some of our favorite foods
that are doing it with health in mind
and lesser ingredients and natural ingredients.
And my hope is that there's a lot of focus and energy
and money going into that right now.
Cause I think that's what we need more of.
I agree with you.
I think that you are absolutely right.
We want minimally processed, less ingredients,
more whole food based analogs for sure.
And the ingredients do vary really widely.
So yeah, I think when you look at the data
on plant-based diets and the healthy plant-based diet index,
which was really interesting data, you see,
as you've pointed out that if you're having an unhealthy
plant-based diet with things like
French fries and ice cream and all the things that you can.
Coconut ice cream and Oreos and potato chips.
Oreos, crisps, potato chips, all of that kind of stuff.
you're not gonna reap the same benefits at all.
And you're right, people can delude themselves
to think, oh, well it's healthy cause it's plant-based.
Well it's not always.
So what's your day in food look like?
Oh I love, oh, what do you call it here?
Oatmeal.
Oatmeal? What do you call it?
Oh, porridge.
Porridge. (laughs)
That's what they call it in.
What's your town called again?
Where I live.
Yeah.
Buckinghamshire.
Right, of course. (laughs)
It's like the British thing ever.
Sorry. (laughs)
In what part of England is it?
Surrey?
It's not, I work in Surrey.
You work in Surrey.
And I live in Buckinghamshire,
which is kind of between, well,
I live sort of near Windsor where the Queen lives.
So that's kind of near where it is.
You'd probably know-
You just get more regal with every moment, Gemma.
Well I'm from Devon, which is not as regal.
That's down by the sea.
Isn't that where Earthling Ed's,
his plant-based fish restaurant is.
Good Catch or something like that?
I don't know., but I'd love it if it was
because Devon needs more plant-based options.
It is, I could be wrong,
but anyway, go ahead a day in the life of food.
Oh yeah.
So I forgot where I was going, so I love porridge,
I love to put flaxseed chia seeds in it.
Berries, alomond butter.
You've got a lovely mixture of whole grains.
You've got your nuts. You've got your seeds.
You've got your antioxidant rich berries.
So yeah, that's a real win for me.
And yeah, in my book, I've got a lot of wholesome recipes
that are also kind of comfort foods,
favorite comfort foods, like mac and cheese,
which obviously doesn't have cheese in it,
but it's a nice kind of whole foods version.
I love things like spaghetti bolognese
but rather than using mince, I use lentils and beans.
Mince is like meatballs, mince is American.
Oh yeah no, I don't know.
Do you not have mince?
It's like.
Mince, M-I-N-C-E, right?
That's how you're spelling it.
It's sort of like ground beef.
It's like ground beef, right?
Yeah, but I don't use.
Yeah, we don't call it that here obviously.
What do you call it?
I don't know, crumbles.
Crumbles. (laughs)
I don't know what we would call it.
What do we call it?
Mince.
We don't have a word for that. (laughs)
Chop (indistinct)
Chop meat-
Chop meat.
I don't know.
There's lots of suggestions from these different
corners of the room.
So I love comfort foods.
Mince and porridge. I eat mince and porridge.
(laughs) So I don't eat much mince at all.
I tend to have like beans and lentils
with my spaghetti bolognese.
I like burritos actually, I'm a big fun of that.
Well, you're in the right place for that.
Yeah, I've seen, yeah, we had some amazing burritos.
We went to Cafe Gratitude.
Oh you did? I lunch there yesterday.
Were you there?
No.
Today you were there?
Day before yesterday.
Yeah, I missed you.
No, it's good there, right?
It's really nice.
Do they have burritos?
They do.
In England, in the UK?
Yeah we do.
And what else?That's it?
No, that's not it. I've got lots of things.
I love a good curry.
I've got a great curry recipe in the book.
Cauliflower and chick pea curry, I love.
I also really like stews
and that's kind of wholesome winter.
I'm thinking of all my favorite winter foods
because we've had a very long winter in the UK,
but now we're coming into the summer.
I do love things like salads.
I add in things like tempeh and tofu into my salads.
And what else?
And is Richard still the cook or do you cook also?
Yeah, I cook, Richard cooks a little bit.
Yeah, cool.
Well, let's round this out with maybe some practical
guidance to kick people into this kind of lifestyle.
Like when somebody comes to you and they're ready to go,
like what kind of words of wisdom can you provide
to empower them to embark upon this journey
with confidence and perhaps a few
practical things that they could do to make it work
within the construct of their busy life?
Well, I think the number one thing
is think of simple swaps that you enjoy,
which we've already touched on.
Number two would be again,
to think about the values that are important to you.
And if you could try and live by those each day,
it really helps you with the food choices you're making,
as well as everything else.
Maybe just three, just three values.
That would be really helpful.
I dunno if you have any sort of top three
that you have in your head right now?
Well, I was just thinking if I was you
and I was seeing patients
and I knew that they could come back and make another
appointment and follow up, I would try to,
because I'm competitive,
I would try to find a way to gamify it.
I'd see like, well, here's your numbers in these categories.
I wanna see them go down 10% in each.
So I want you to come back in 30 days
and we're gonna do it again, so it start,
it's almost like goal oriented.
Yeah it's very practical.
Here's what we're driving towards.
And if you can come back
every 30 days or every 60 days or something like that,
and we can evaluate the progress,
that creates a level of accountability and engagement.
Yeah, I do that at work. I definitely do.
And it's quite nice because you've got actual numbers
to work with and you have a goal for people to have in mind.
I think making those goals specific
and time orientated really helps.
So I mean, generally for people at home,
if you want to do that for yourselves,
then maybe you could get your blood test done,
your blood work done, and then decide, okay,
in the course of four or eight weeks,
I'm gonna get to this number
and this is how I'm gonna do it.
But certainly my practice,
I found that with my patients
getting average blood sugar readings,
getting cholesterol or lipid panel profile
or blood pressure readings actually,
they can change over time as well with nutrition.
It's quite nice to then be able to have that accountability,
to be able to bring them back and to encourage them as well.
I think for some of my patients then gamifying,
it is good, but for others,
they just tend to need that little bit of extra
like compassion and care and
make sure that they know that I'm gonna be there
and I'm gonna check it again when they come back.
So yeah, it's a good strategy.
I also think being specific,
it's fine to say it's okay to do this gradually,
but how are you specifically going to accomplish that?
Because to just say, well,
I'm just gonna try and I'm gonna start eating more plants
seems very vague, but if you say, listen,
I know you love cream in your coffee.
So for the next 30 days,
you're gonna do almond milk or soy milk or whatever it is.
And you're just gonna master that one thing.
Like that's all you have to do is like that one thing.
And it makes it very doable because,
and it's kind of like a go, no go thing.
Right you can wrap your head around it.
This is what I'm doing.
And then after 30, 60 days of that,
it's like, okay, well, that's just,
I don't even think about that anymore.
What's the next thing that I can do?
Yeah exactly.
And I think that makes it more like,
'cause the human brain is weird, right.
And if you're just like,
well I'm just gonna eat more plants.
Like what does that mean, right.
And I think that will wan in terms of how people are
kind of consciously engaging with each meal and each food
choice that they're making throughout the day.
Yeah, you're right.
And it's also so individual to people as well.
So I could have one person sitting in front of me
who thinks, okay,
well I can start with my milk and I'll have someone else
sitting in front of me that thinks, okay,
well I know I can just start with my breakfasts and I'll
have someone else sitting in front of me that thinks, okay,
well I know I can just start with two tablespoons
of milled flaxseed a day.
And then, so it really depends on the person,
what route I go down.
Based on what they feel they can achieve based on what they
already are doing, which is, yeah.
It's quite good to individualize it in that way
and make it really super specific.
I also think people future trip,
I'm sure they say to you, I can't do it
'cause I have to go to a wedding this summer,
in four months or something like that.
It's like, that doesn't matter.
Like this is a sober thing, it's like,
what are you doing today?
Can your head hit the pillow sober tonight?
That's all you have to worry about.
What is your next food choice when you, okay,
you're gonna go to the grocery store today?
Like what are you gonna buy?
Like just focusing on making that next right choice
and not worrying about what you're gonna do tomorrow.
Obviously with food, there is some planning involved,
like you're getting food for the next day
or for the following week.
But to the extent that you can just be rooted in the moment
and not freak out about like the rest of your life or,
oh my God, I'm never gonna have this food ever again.
That's so true.
'Cause I think that really works
at cross purposes with the goal.
It's so true. That is so true.
And I think about that in other aspects of life as well,
you can generally manage to do something just for today.
You know you can manage to make the right kind
of choice for your health and body just for today.
Or you can choose not to feel angry just for today
or you can choose not to worry
about something just for today.
And this is a slight tangent,
but I actually have this daily mantra that I do,
which is exactly that.
It's in Japanese and in English it means
just for today, do not be angry, do be worried, be grateful,
do your duties fully, and be kind to all living things.
And that is the mantra that I actually repeat to myself
twice a day, every day in Japanese.
And it's just for today.
Well, you know what I'm gonna say right now.
I'm gonna make you do it in Japanese.
Okay.
Oh gosh, okay.
The pressure's on.
(speaking in foreign language)
That's beautiful.
I think that's a good place to end it.
I can't imagine a better ending than with that mantra.
It's called the gokai.
The gokai, where did you find that?
It's part of my Jekiden and Reiki practice,
which is a whole other topic.
That's a whole other, yeah, that's a whole there,
I know a little bit about that,
but that's a whole other podcast.
Next time.
But yeah.
Next house call.
It's a great way of living, being, thinking.
You don't have to put pressure on yourself
to be your best self every day.
Just try and do it today.
"The Plant Power Doctor"
paid a house call today and I think
we're all the better for it.
Thank you, Gemma.
Thank you, Rich.
Thank you for all that you do.
I appreciate you.
The new book is "The Plant Power Doctor"
available everywhere.
Pick it up, it is quite an accomplishment,
a beautiful book, beautiful photographs, plenty of recipes,
but amazing takeaways to improve your life on the daily.
Thank you.
So I wish you well and come back
and talk to me again sometime.
I can't wait for the next time.
I gotta make it out to London.
I'm trying to figure that out at some point.
When you do, I'll be there.
We'll both be there.
We'll cook you amazing food.
You can stay with us if you want to.
Excellent, in Buckinghamshire.
In Buckinghamshire. (laughs)
I feel like I have to see it now
because in my mind there's, just beef eaters everywhere and.
No, no, it's...
Well Windsor, yes, we could take you to Windsor,
which is only a 10 minute drive away
and you'll see beef eaters everywhere there. (laughs)
Good that's a promise.
And final thing, if people want to learn more about you,
where's the best place to have them go?
You do a lot on Instagram.
I do a lot on Instagram.
Plant Power Doctor on Instagram,
but my website's got loads of free resources,
gemmanewman.com.
So yeah check that out as well.
All right thanks, peace.
Peace and plants.
Plants.
(upbeat music)